let's jump into the black members my
aunt my anarchist economist right here
we got uh we got some news i mean uh so
the first story that we saw about elon
musk was that he was saying people gotta
have more babies and then steve you
brought up that he was like yeah and he
also said he's gonna implant chimp chips
and people not chimps chips
in people he did it to a monkey first
well check out the story from daily mail
elon musk says neural link could start
implanting chips in humans in 2022
people with severe spinal injuries would
get the tech the billionaire says could
help them walk again
yeah that's the trojan horse we're going
to save the guys with the paraplegics
and it's all it's that's part of it's
all great okay but but this neuralink is
quite dangerous
two tv shows i want to reference as we
get into this
outer limits and stargate
sg1 in there's an outer limits uh
episode where everyone's got a device on
their faces that connects them to the
stream of data
but the stream is a collective uh
essentially that it's an ai that
effectively controls people's minds but
they think they're getting clean
information they think they're they're
being shown the truth so they act upon
what the information they're given is
although it's seeking to protect itself
in stargate sg-1 they go to a place
where everyone's slowly dying off and
they're all you know connected to this
like ai system that erases their
memories as people die so they don't
know what's actually going on wow this
is these are the dangers of what you
what you get with like a neural link
there's i i don't think this is true but
i was told the lore of the borg and star
trek third show is that they were like
regular are you familiar with the
concept of the borg no they're an alien
uh in star trek the next generation they
fly around these big cubes and they say
you will be assimilated resistance is
futile
they're they are cybernetic they are all
one hive mind and they implant you with
chips to sync your brain up to their
machine and the idea i guess was again i
don't know if this is actually part of
the star trek lore but this is what i
was told they were regular people
developing medical technology
just like us and they started implanting
more and more and more until they
started connecting and then the natural
process by which they connected their
minds created a hive mind naturally so
we look at what elon musk is doing and
he says we're going to heal people how
long until
it's twitter but it is on steroids
you've got everyone just marching in
lockstep behind a tribal ideology this
is why facebook to meta look you have
the convergence of
a bunch of technologies that are
happening here advanced chip design
which is neuralink you have artificial
general intelligence which is artificial
intelligence that kind of recreates
itself you have regenerative robotics
you have crispy advances in
biotechnology the convergence of those
in a couple of other industries are
converging on this point called the
singularity on this side of that point
is homo sapiens on the other side of
that it's let's say it's homo sapiens
plus okay and and this is
hey on climate change
in all that is that an immediate crisis
i don't know i'm not a climate change
denier but i can look at the evidence
and don't know if it's absolutely as
immediate as they say the immediate one
i can tell you
is this crisis of we're coming towards
this because there's no regulation on
this once again your audience has to
understand
as happened with shipping all the jobs
over to china it's your money the great
the greek tragedy part of this
everything about the singularity is
financed by the pension funds of the
deplorables in this country it's it's
they are the venture capital front
remember the venture capital firms the
private equity firms the hedge funds
it's all your money from your pension
funds from your from your insurance
companies from your banks that's the
money's done and what they're doing
is coming up with uh with the
convergence of this
that
who knows you know they're going to be
designer who knows how this goes it is
hurtling so fast and now this is the
thing about schmidt in that report there
and if you read kissinger and schmidt's
book they're telling you
well guys hey guess what we don't have
we don't have a choice here because it's
an arms race the most dangerous weapons
in the history of mankind are being
developed right now in artificial
intelligence oh by the way the chinese
are here the russians here so we have to
get into this arms race so now you're
going to have this exponential growth of
this in 30 years there's going to be
some 18 year old who's had a neural link
since he was born
and he's going to be like what's the big
deal i mean we've always had the chip
we've always been implanted the okay at
front national uh national rally the
political group in france uh in january
of this year
they they had their annual meeting at
kickoff meeting and they had a bunch of
french thinkers come up and address them
about what's happening in the economy
what's happening in future a guy stood
up one of the top biotech investors in
in france and said
the um
the first
post
homo sap full homo sapien
has been born
today and they will be something that is
post man okay because of either a chip
artificial intelligence is implanted who
knows my point is if you look at it
you've got all these industries going
down this path totally unregulated with
nobody looking you've got darpa your tax
dollars you have private equity you've
got stuff happening in china south korea
in in eastern europe nobody knows what's
going on right and but you're seeing
hints of it you're hearing hints of it
from the schmitz of the world and from
people talking about national security
saying well you know there's some
artificial
intelligence weapons that could be you
know very scary got the hype people are
sitting there going you got the guy came
out the other day on the defense
department saying we're so far behind
where the chinese are okay then you
don't even talk about the crisper part
which could get to the biological
weapons we have no earthy idea what's
going on we have no ability to control
it right now because look i'm a fighter
and i fought globalization and i'll take
on a lot of fights this one right here
you kind of sit there and go where do we
even start why would the elites want the
plebs to be in their neural link network
they don't here's what
it was jane goodall said the other day
is that they they um
she said the other day the carrying
capacity
their mentality
is that
because you can't solve the global cri
the math doesn't work to solve anything
on the climate change crisis at the
scale you have of people today of seven
billion people okay her thing was hey
the carrying capacity of earth that's
correct is 500 million so what the at
least
what's what the elites want is 500
million right and so they say the
replacement strategy it's not about
whites versus hispanics versus blacks
it's about homo sapiens versus the
elites want and all of them focus on
this one thing which is life extension
right
veritas the veritas guys when they were
in the facebook that facebook you know
he's talking up the young girl and being
a big shot and talking about how they
work the election against trump the last
part of it's the buried lead he goes oh
by the way all zuckerberg and the white
spend their time on is liv his eternal
life and met adversity he's the one that
dropped the bomb on meta that they're
going to a whole different thing of the
embodied internet and that's where they
spend the time this the the
you make us you make a big deal about
this election they don't spend any time
on that they really spend their time on
this the elites in the world are
spending their time now financing and
looking at extending life because all of
them are godless they're all atheistic
materialists they want to live forever
okay they're in back of this whole thing
and this is not a conspiracy theory
there's no conspiracy theory look at
look at his facebook and meta and they
have enough power and influence and
money to do so and it's not just
countries but steve it's not just
foreign countries it's it's amazon it's
google it's developing artificial
intelligence also working with china in
order to do zuckerberg google these are
like we're back in the in the middle
ages we have city states
amazon and google and that's why i'm a
radical populist in this these companies
immediately have to be taken over
immediately have to be controlled like
public utilities they have to get seven
percent returns they have to be under
the control of the people of this
country they have to be controlled like
the regional belt operating companies
were back in the in the 50s and 60s the
bell thing they have to be treated as
public utilities you cannot let a
handful of people okay on the
deplorables money remember zuckerberg
these guys had no cash in the beginning
this was all their money now these
companies are out of control to me meta
before you get to the embodied internet
we ought to understand what the embodied
internet is going to be to the people
look at the ad they have at this this
meta ad you see with the the metaverse
matter you you talk about mankind being
asleep and just sleep walking through
life you look at that that that ad that
ad is like oh we're gonna enter we're
gonna entice you into this new living
new pod living and you're going to be
you're going to be totally asleep this
is the sleep of mankind did you see the
suicide pods assisted pods in
switzerland no yeah
elon musk even even has monkeys with
brain chips that are playing video games
right now as we're speaking as the world
economic forum literally just released
the statement with one of its
representatives talking about how we
need a population of the world that's
that was 500 years ago 500 years ago the
population of the world was 461 million
people and they're talking about
overpopulation according to all the
world's problems this is nice this is
not some schmendrick this is jane
goodall now she's been saying it forever
but she says they asked her what's a
base and i've heard this from people
they call it the carrying capacity of
the earth they've run the numbers on
this this is not i'm not conspiracy
theory guy this is something they work
on all the time and you can see
by these different technologies it
shouldn't be lost on people when china
went to the when the ccp went to 10
years ago made in china 2025 which they
never talk about anymore because they
realize they got people's attention on
that the top of the top 10 industries
they said they're the 10 industries they
were going to dominate by the year 2025
the top six
were the industries that converge into
the singularity okay crispr advanced
chip design artificial intelligence
artificial general intelligence robotics
robotics regenerative robotics
this is happening today this is not
science fiction we've hired by the way
guys at uh war room joe allen runs a
team right we're adding more people to
it just to focus on transhumanism
because i keep telling people set
climate change off the side that may be
maybe not who knows okay but this is
real and this is going to happen not in
50 years not in 30 years in
10 years
i think you're going to hit the
singularity what does that mean that
means you're going to have the ability
to have a post homo sapien either
between neurolink artificial
intelligence a combination of
biotechnology
what does that mean for our lives what
will we experience people tapped into
the system the system that they control
yeah exactly first off you're going to
have somebody that you're going to have
your kids are going to be competing or
could compete against people about us um
beings that are just not homo sapiens as
as we know it right people that through
their own native intelligence hard work
diligence but have either have chips in
them have artificial intelligence have
biological have been biologically a
change somehow right through crispr or
other technologies
that are in designer designer
species that are over and above now how
is that supposed to compete in in in in
college in education for jobs all of a
sudden you're you're not you're in a
different you're in a species that's not
the highest species right so you're
you're a homo sapien there's a homo
sapien plus now i realize a lot of
people say bannon's lost it no no no no
no no no you're absolutely right because
i've been researching and studying this
thing for 20 years they're laying the
groundwork right now especially with the
future that you're talking about where
you're going to have to have a
government approved medical procedure to
be a part of society and you will be
kicked out of society you won't have a
good social crisis or unless you have
that if you think i'm crazy if you think
i'm crazy go to every pr let's go to
every major private venture capital firm
in the country on their annual meeting
where they put up their deals well steve
you look at their deals in technology
and artificial intelligence and machine
learning and biotechnology it lines up
to one of these verticals and these
people will tell you these verticals are
converging they're converging to a point
called with ray kurzweil kurzweil who
was thought of as a nut case when he
came up with this concept 20 years ago
kurzweil the singularity he's the evp
of research and development for wait for
it google okay these are the guy
deepmind you've got some obviously the
smartest guys in the world are working
on these things and they're converging
and this is a crisis that's building up
because this is the kind of thing like
how do you even regulate it how do you
how do you how do you govern it how and
so all this science fiction has been
written about
this is now science fact
look elon musk who's who's
people that know him will tell you
maybe not the best manager in the world
but he's one of the top engineers in the
world when that guy comes out and says
in the fall of
2022
that would be less than a year away i'm
going to be able to insert a chip into a
human mind okay a human mind that's
going to take care of somebody who's
been apparent no spinal cord is a
paraplegic that's where it's going to
start okay but trust me they've got
stuff in the neurolink lab right now
that ain't just working on paraplegics
it just it started with the monkey
controlling a video game with the chip
implanted in its head and there's a
reason a lot of the top globalist a lot
of the top corporatists are eugenicist
believe in population control and
ultimately are transhumanists who want
to transcend the human spirit the human
energy into their own form of reality
where they control every aspect of it
that's all essentially the end game it
sounds crazy but there's a lot of insane
technological advancements that we don't
even know about that we should be
talking about that
i can't believe i'm saying this
i believe in anarchy should be some
regulations surrounding oh no no no no
no no it has to be regular first off we
need this can't believe i'm saying
eric schmidt came out with this uh i
think 800 page report about a year ago
on artificial intelligence that he had
done for the defense department and he
had done it on on on trump's watch
he signaled right there and he said
we're in an arms race and china is so
far advanced and you've heard guys come
out since then including the people at
the pentagon that are in charge of
reference talent saying say hey we're so
far behind all of a sudden you get into
an arms race on this thing it's your
nuclear weapons you started at something
at nagasaki and hiroshima that was one
thing and now because of the perfection
of it right think about it for a second
there's more computing capacity in that
phone than there was in the kennedy
space center when a man went to the moon
that's the other thing is they got a
fact our joe allen there's an analysis
out
by a guy i think he's at mit enjoy
apologize don't get right
moore's law which is the driver of the
of the chip that goes in your brain from
elon moss is moore's law every 18 months
the computing capacity is going they're
going to cut a size and it's going to
double whatever every two years computer
power doubles doubles it's about 18
months that's moore's law but two years
in a.i
the guy did the analysis in a.i joe
allen's fact got it up on warren.org uh
a summary of the article
he said hey they've got a moore's law on
artificial intelligence but it's not
doubling every 18 months
it's 6x yep it's potential growth that
just goes up dramatically you know what
the event horizon is when ai gains the
ability to code itself artificial
general intelligence because you have
artificial intelligence and regenerative
robotics when it codes itself as
artificial general intelligence now some
guys will tell you that's a fantasy
it'll never be able to happen there's
other guys that say hey i think we're on
the glideslope indicator for like 10
years
my point we don't know but what we do
know is a massive amount of capital of
your capital of people's capital is
going into this and it's not being
discussed darpa
your tax dollars to the federal
government okay your all these
universities everybody goes to are
massive research labs for this remember
the university of north carolina was one
of the biggest testing groups for
uh for the
starting the ccp virus and nobody knew
what went on at chapel hill okay there
are things at every research university
in the country tremendous amount of
resources on your tax dollars and all
your all your pension funds are fueling
this right now eli and nobody and nobody
talks about elon musk drops this thing
out whoa look at this and it's always
some good will thing which is fine this
is to help paraplegic people and people
can never move well hey look trust me
that's the first thing they're leading
with they've got a whole raft of r d
internally that ain't just helping the
the people that are that are crippled
yeah sure and bill gates is working on
digital contraception that you could
control for a button for people's
convenience sure and and bannon gets an
incredible amount of government money
but it's also being financed in another
way right now when you have the largest
uh sorry
sorry sorry not ban it but musk
that's an incredible muslim
let's get something that's
slippery
musk gets an incredible amount of money
it's a great world government but
there's also the largest transfer of
wealth in recorded human history
happening right now taking money from
the poor and middle class and literally
being transferred to the billionaire
class that's building the prison
building this online technocracy that
we're going to be living in
one of the reasons we're doing
transhumanism i said this in a speech in
italy uh a couple of years ago
i said look
globalization came about because all
these forces kind of came together and
nobody stopped it and nobody talked
about it it was all supposed to be great
and turned out not to be great it turned
out to have many more
more bad things happen then good things
happen and that's why you have the
stripping away of jobs uh you know what
happened in the united states all the
factories leaving et cetera
transhumanism is the same thing except
it's to the 10th scale because
globalization you can start to unwind it
it's tough but we are unwanting it to a
large extent throughout the world
transhumanism once you hit the
singularity and you're on the other side
of it you can't put that genie back in
the bottle the only point i make is that
there's so much research going on and
you got to avoid the thing of conspiracy
theories and and you know half-baked
ideas just look at the verticals just
take the chinese what they try to
dominate take those same verticals look
what's happening in the united states go
to drudge i mean drudge has got one of
the best transhumanist sections now it's
all over the page you got artificial
intelligence here you got robotics here
you got things but if you look at just
the news every day that's coming out and
that's only going to accelerate it's
going to accelerate at an accelerating
speed and we need to get ahead of that
and we've looked at it now they're going
to celebrate it they're going to they're
going to create that neuralink chip
which is going to grant you access to
skyrim don't you want to be the noble
warrior fighting the dragon just implant
the chip and plug on it baby well the
company
the companies building it are the ones
already helping influence elections so
when we look at google when we look at
amazon we see them already controlling
the minds of the people we see them
controlling culture we see them
controlling entertainment so of course
they're going to build a support system
that's going to have people saying yes
please inject me with this later they're
going to create chips where i can read
it's read-only so i can read everybody's
brain i'm basically part of the
collective i can read the internet i can
read everything then they're going to
have a certain class of people that
can't afford or whatever they're going
to have right chips where you can write
on their brain any of us in the class of
read only of our elite class can write
on their brains and basically mind
control them if you opt out this is like
the vaccine manager if you opt out
remember they're trying to make you an
untouchable right now if you're
whether you're an anti-vaxxer or vaccine
hesitant or vaccine resistant okay
they're trying to other you
across the crowd look what's happening
in russia
things that would be conspiracy theories
in the summer are now facts austria says
everybody that's unvaccinated is going
to be locked down then we're going to
lock everybody down oh by the way on one
february mandatory vaccination for the
entire nation germany says the same
thing it's going to happen we're going
to put in front of the bundestag in
early february mandatory vaccinations
things people would say oh that's bannon
and tim poole and all these crazies
these are all facts coming together now
so if you opt out of if you opt out of
the singularity
from a moral or religious or spiritual
point of view if you think that's going
to make did you the vaccine mandate look
like a kid like a garden party did you
see in sweden they're already implanting
chips in their hands i saw that what
they that could just be some trendy
people trying to you know no but it is
true but but
it is but it's a it's a it's a it's a
beta site test that's what they're they
they all this stuff's going to be
basically
the vera chip thing for over a decade
how long has it been if you combine it
all if you look at it and then you're
gonna have a bombshell oh by the way
in uh in in in the fall of 22 we're
gonna have the ability to put a silicon
chip
right in your brain
to make the uh the people that can't
walk and can't move will be able to do
all of their functions think about that
for a second what we have not been able
to do with medicine and that's just the
first of many you're gonna see these
announcements here's here's the issue to
elaborate on what ian said about read
only and write he's act actually i think
what he
may be missing is that it's not going to
be that read only is available available
for the people you get your neural link
chip there's going to be police chips
the police are granted a chip that can
read your chip
it's not about whether you you think
they're going to give you
the ability to read someone else's
private info no no the authorities will
however walk up and say what are you
doing here ah that's a lie i can see it
i've got a read chip then there's going
to be high ranking elites with the right
chip which can change what's in your
chip and can shut you out can shoot you
down law enforcement might be able to do
that but imagine that if every venture
capital firm had a public presentation
and went online had a public
presentation and say here's where our
investments are here's what these
companies look like in five or ten years
here's what the technology is going to
be developed the american people would
be
shocked they won what what's going on
here who approved this they won't need
tasers ever again
if they can give you the ability to
connect your spine they can certainly
interrupt that signal can't they
so the police officer walks up and the
person tries to run and then also the
person just stops dead in their tracks
why because the police have brought have
the ability to you know through
bluetooth within certain range disable
motor functions if the chips can grant
it certainly they can interrupt those
signals
is that a possibility i think it
certainly is i don't know about in 10
years because they got to get everyone
to view this as normal first that's like
that's why i said in 30 years there's
going to be some 18 year old who's like
you guys why are you complaining
whatever we've always had our chips i
mean how many people make videos today
where they're like the government is
forcing us to register a number with
them in order to live and work and get
access to public accommodation this is a
violation of our civil rights nobody not
a single person is putting out videos
complaining about social security
numbers so in 30 years not a single
person will be complaining about the
singularity they'll be in it and they'll
be happy they'll also own nothing when
putin's talking about weaponizing
artificial intelligence i don't think
many people even realize or understand
or could even comprehend the ways that
it could be used against populations so
that's one way one basic way that you're
explaining it but there's multiple
personalities when you have an
intelligence that is higher than you
higher than any
smart person in this entire world and
when you have that capability when you
have that power how can you control it
how can you stop someone who's a
megalomaniac from wielding it that's the
real question that i think we should be
asking ourselves especially with the
consequences someone someone said it's
been two years and there are already
camps in australia
no due process you're taken from your
home you are placed in the camp no due
process let me say another thing about
many of the scientists and technology uh
technologists that are in these
different verticals
also understand the deep
moral and ethical problems that they
face i think it's dr
doudna who the book uh isaacson's book
that won the uh pulitzer prize i think
she won the nobel prize i think they
went to public surprise the book about
her in crispr
her book
the book she actually wrote that came
out before that book was her doubts
about and questions
about bioethics
so people in these different areas
there's many people right now that are
very concerned and if you talk to them
off the record
right they're very concerned about where
all this is heading whereas the benefits
may be tremendous in combination or
where we're heading hasn't been thought
through yet what do you think about the
mark of the beast
what do you mean the mark of the beast
that you cannot buy sell or trade
without the mark of the beast it's uh
from what revelation is that
yes i know the apocalypse well i didn't
know that um you didn't know that you
didn't know that i didn't know the buy
seller trade i just assumed like my my
general understanding without having
looked into it was just that you know
the apocalypse would happen and people
have this mark and then someone
mentioned with the market you could not
buy sell or trade unless you you know
had the mark of the beast and i'm like
okay that's really specific that's kind
of crazy right
although i do think there's been many
you know instances i mean nazi germany
for instance where your papers where
they've implemented some kind of mandate
but you know people now in in the chat
are alluding to well that's the vaccine
passport yeah the vaccine passes it's an
entry level entry-level part of that but
it's social credit scores social credit
scores and the results you have a social
credit score here right social credit
score here that's why you're deeply
that's where you're dealing platform
they're de-financed and de-banked right
anybody's considered an insurrectionist
or anybody to consider anything with six
uh january has been de-platformed or
they look donald trump let's
he's starting his own social media
company now because as
commander-in-chief before he's out of
office he was de-platformed by the
social media you know miles told me
years ago he said as powerful as nuclear
weapons are social media is 10 times
more powerful and the chinese companies
party know it that's why they
decapitated that's where they made 19
they made a decision to go to their own
technology companies to start to control
these companies the west that's why they
eviscerated the tech companies back in
the spring of this year where i think it
was 600
billion dollars of market cap that was
lost of american pension fund money to
get control of it so we live in era
social credit scores that that's not
theory that's practice and yeah and it's
also with the esg with major
corporations and it's also with another
corporate social credit score that
people don't even know about with
corporations leveling you giving you a
score on on not just what they could
sell you but your beliefs and your
systems as well look new york city just
came out the other day de blasio said by
december 27th that's in what three weeks
there's gonna be mandatory vaccinations
for private companies and and children
from five to eleven are gonna have to
have a pass yeah they're gonna have to
have a passport to get in basically any
function
did you see the prime minister i think
in new zealand said this will never end
i think you tweeted that yep um
what's your name jacinda or something
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive
segments on our website where we are
unrestricted in what we talk about so
you'll definitely not want to miss it
thanks for hanging out we'll see you all
next time
you